hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my newsletter subscribers
the one who is an architect he's got no
money and he's trying to get to the
survival point with this business and I
know that's a really tough place to be
you've just started the business and
you're not making enough money to pay
your bills and put food on the table and
is only so long you can last so get into
survival point is a super important step
for your company you may have really big
vision for where you want to go and huge
dreams for what you want to accomplish
but you got to start I'd be able to
support yourself at the kind of bare
minimum so what i thought i would do is
use the whiteboard and explain what i
would do if i was starting up in this
position with fawn so the first thing
I'm seeing here obviously we've got no
money right and I'm sure a lot of you
guys can appreciate that even as you get
your business to bigger point money is
always an issue and you have to make
sure that you are using it correctly
stretching as far as you can go the good
news is we're in a service type of
business here so we don't need a lot of
money to get it going and I don't advise
spending a lot of money for
entrepreneurs what we need is a lot of
hustle and I know you guys can hustle
and I hustled a lot to get my business
going so I hope you guys can do the same
the first thing I would do is go start
talking to customers and what I want to
do here is I'm not trying to sell them
I'm not going insane hey I'm the
greatest new architect on the block
please hire me what I'm doing is going
in and listening to the challenges that
they have understand their market a
little bit better think about who they
are currently working with and ask them
if there is anything that they're
missing from their current suppliers so
you might not be able to displace acker
inspire that they're using but there
might be additional services that
they're not happy with from their
current supplier or they're not getting
from the current supplier so that could
be you coming in to seize the day so I'm
going in listening getting feedback
trying to be helpful trying to be a
resource and not selling
okay nobody wants to be sold to
especially by you know startup
entrepreneurs so go in be a resource
what's not going to get me is a small
job and this is your goal starting off
okay you're not going to go in and get
huge contracts if you can go in and get
huge contracts that's a bonus but most
scenarios if you're a new guy coming in
you're going to be getting the little
contracts and it's a great opportunity
because what it is is a foot in the door
and an opportunity for you to prove
yourself so what you want to do even if
it's a really low pain entry-level type
of assignment what you want to do is
over the liver like crazy over the liver
you want to be seen as a guy who
delivers results and that's gonna get
you from there bigger jobs which is what
we want and more referrals referrals
from either within the business or two
colleagues okay you have to over-deliver
and i'll give you a quick example from
my business that might help you guys out
and especially youth one so I was
recently hired to create some blog posts
for a company and they said we'd like to
hire you to write three to five hundred
words for a blog and provide some Valley
for entrepreneurs but no problem I can
do that instead of just right at three
to five hundred words i wrote 1,500
words i went way beyond went three times
longer than what they asked for and then
not only that i just create a blog post
which is what most ever the people did
when they got hired i created a video
that go along with it i promoted on my
newsletter list I've put on my Twitter
list and YouTube and all the social
media and we had over 10 times the
amount of traffic to our posts compared
to everybody else that was on the site
so what happens the company wants to
hire me back and you want to hire me for
bigger jobs right so we've just signed a
new agreement tripled the budget for the
post and I've been able to go and get
other clients on board at much higher
rates as well and it all came from over
delivering so you have the requirements
but you
have to go way way way above that if you
want to be seen as the guy to stand out
that they're going to want to hire for
future projects okay so over deliver on
the first project that you get and then
an all future project as well the next
thing I would do obviously we're talking
to customers is a great thing but we are
all about the hustle so the next thing I
would also do is try to get some press
ok and again it doesn't have to cost you
money it's just a time investment and
you have a lot of time you don't have a
lot of money so i would start talking to
local press national press international
press and also talk to bloggers and see
if you can offer guest blog posts for
their blog and what it helps you do is
get seen as the expert in your industry
if you're starting to business you're an
entrepreneur you have to know what
you're doing right so you better be an
expert in your field of interest and the
media is always looking for experts to
talk about the challenges that they see
in the marketplace so when I win a
newspaper or a different reporter is
creating a story they're looking for
experts a comment so why can't you be
that expert so I'd reach out to all the
different media outlets that i can again
we're going local we're going national
we're looking for any international ones
like Todd that fit our market and then
also offered a guest blog so look for
bloggers who target your market and
offer to write them a guest post to show
your expertise and offer a lot of value
to them the last thing I would do again
all under hustle is I would set up my
website and you may not have a lot of
technical expertise but you can find
somebody to help you wrote it doesn't
have to cost you any money find somebody
who you know friend family owes you a
favor do barter services whatever it is
get a website up make it look good
simple doesn't have to be complex and
expensive just simple clean especially
if you're in design it should look
pretty nice from here I would make sure
that i'm adding content again showing
that i'm an expert and hopefully people
will then find me through different
search engines and get me some business
so again you don't have to worry about
not having a lot
money it's not really how much resources
you have to start up the business it's
more how resourceful you are and it all
comes from hustle okay so talk to
customers get some press set up your
website and you're on the way to getting
not only to the survival stage but much
further along and hopefully building it
on super successful business so good
luck one I hope that helps if you guys
like the video I'd love to hear you have
to say come on leave a comment
underneath and also always appreciate
any thumbs ups you want to give the
video it helps me know which ones you
like and which ones if you don't like as
much so thank you and we'll see you on
the next episode
you